Oh-
That's just sweet.
Appreciate that.
My God.
I am loving the show so much.
I'm so in,
and your characters, they're,
they're very complex people, to say the least.
'Cause you're trying not to say something horrible?
Well, there is a lack of, you know, pure intentions,
(Claire laughs)
but does that make for juicier roles to play
and characters to watch as an audience?
Yeah, I think it's, I think so.
It's always better to play people who behave badly.
I think.
And probably in life it's better to...
No, no I'm not gonna say that.
No, don't say that.
(Drew laughs)
But it is nice.
It's nice to step outside of,
kind of behaving yourself
and to say the things you wanna say
and do the things you wanna do
and not really care about the consequences.
And because they're such awful people
it's kind of nice to watch the train wreck.
Yes.
Yeah, (laughs)
Yes, and yet I feel like I've been in that relationship.
(they laugh)
I did have a little PTSD watching it,
I kid you not.
'Cause I was with some-
Who was it, Drew?
(they laugh)
Say it. Say it!
I'll never tell.
I'll never tell, but I,
I was in a relationship with someone where,
overnight, I thought I was with one person
and all of a sudden they were not that person anymore.
Hmm.
Hm-mm.
And I, that happened.
We have a relationship?
What?
(all laugh)
No, but you are with someone who I'm also in love with,
Jennifer Connolly is your wife!
She is.
Oh my God.
I love her so much.
(audience applauds)
I mean, (sighs) have you always been in love with her?
Did you see her in "Labyrinth"?
Is that true?
Yes, I did.
Well, yes I did.
Everybody saw her in Labyrinth.
And was that the moment?
Yes, but I don't think I was alone in that.
You know, I think every other 10 year old boy
had a similar sort of awakening, (chuckles) as it were.
That's right.
(audience applauds)
Funny enough, I think-
This story makes me sound like a weird stalker.
I was just gonna say-
And then 20 years later,
having watched her comings and goings.
(they chuckle)
I also loved her.
I just, I, everything.
And she's in the new "Top Gun" movie,
which I've seen the trailer for 15 times.
(audience applauds)
Yeah
The movie's fantastic.
I've seen it.
Did she enjoy working with Tom Cruise?
She did.
I mean, I think it was a little terrifying,
'cause he would say things like
"So we're gonna shoot this and I'm gonna fly the plane
and you're getting in the plane."
And she's like, "Wha?" You know?
So I think that was a little terrifying.
And what about-
Turns out he's a great pilot, of course.
What about-
Luckily. (laughs)
The motorcycle?
I see them on a motorcycle
and I can always tell that he is not tethered to anything.
He is riding that beast into the sunset
with no blanks given.
What was, I mean
that must have been ex, like terrifying and exciting,
but to let Tom Cruise just take the wheel?
Yeah, I think it's sort of hard
to stay looking glamorous at 80 miles an hour
with wind in your eyes, you know?
"Jen you look like you're crying."
"Yes, 'cause it's 80 miles an hour
and there's wind in my eyes."
According to the trailer, she pulls it off.
She does.
And you are Vision.
I am.
I mean-
(audience applauds and cheers)
Yes.
Katheryn Hahn came on the show.
I tried everything I could to poke and prod
and goad and reverse psychology and gaslight
to get any information out of her whatsoever.
I'll just give it you, what do you need?
Oh, (laughs)
(audience laughs)
I mean it ends on a cliff hanger and is it true?
Marvel doesn't like cliff hangers,
there's such a purpose behind that.
What's gonna happen with Vision?
Well, Drew, uh,
(audience laughs)
I don't know.
I actually don't know,
but I do know that you're right
that Kevin Feige doesn't like loose ends
and I do fly away at the end,
so I'm hoping that there will be a future for Vision.
If only that I can keep my kids in private school.
(audience laughs)
(Claire laughs)
According to that performance,
you will definitely be back,
because you were so wonderful in that role.
Thank you very much.
You're strong.
You're romantic.
You made all of us women weak in the knees.
Seriously, when you're like,
"Yes, my love"
(audience applauds)
We're all like,
"Why is no man saying that to me?"
Oh my God, it's so great.
Well, I had a team of women writers. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
Well that doesn't hurt,
but you still have to be the one
with that chemistry and pulling it off
at the end of the day.
So well done, all of you guys.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
(bright theme music)